hey what's going on is Bill Byrne it's
time for the Monday morning podcast from
Monday February 29th 2016 happy ly oh
happy leap year and happy birthday to
the poor sad [ __ ] who only have a
birthday once every four years you know
good lord can you imagine going on that
first date with that broad bitching
about that I always felt left out it was
like everybody else had a birthday every
single year it was like I was zero then
I was four then I was eight
[Music]
you know she'd be in good shape though
huh
eating [ __ ] 75% less birthday
birthday cake every year right no wait
how does that math work out if in four
years you had four slices of cake all
right but you'll pour in the leap year
you only had one yeah that percentage
doesn't work because you know you have
one somebody else says to they've got a
100% more than you got right yeah
provided that they're equals slices no
jaysis bill you're gonna break out
fractions I think I've gotta still
little birthday cake fractions all right
so then they're getting [ __ ] 300%
more cake than you are man I pay you
know something I bet anybody who's born
on February 29th is either a miserable
[ __ ] or just one of the coolest
laid-back people like you know oh my god
another birthday aren't the years flying
by no no they're not actually to be
honest with you that's kind of weird so
like when the [ __ ] are you actually like
like say when you're 29 you know that
doesn't work do you 28 it's got to be
for us right
wait you're zero Jesus Christ it should
be [ __ ] annoying zero if you had a
baby born on the 29th right you beef you
zero the first year all right one two
three no four it'd be back again to four
right I don't [ __ ] know all I know is
that somebody's birthday today and it
hasn't been their birthday since 2012 so
happy [ __ ] birthday well is
work out 16 15 14 13 12 would be five
years ago I can't [ __ ] do it I don't
know when it was so once every three
years
Jesus anything that happens every four
years usually sucks people's birthdays
on leap year World Cup soccer the
Olympics you know actually like Olympic
hockey but then I hate all those [ __ ]
douches who never watch hockey maybe
like see if it was like this I would
watch it all the time what only two
weeks long with no fighting you [ __ ]
douche beat it nobody cares whether you
watch it or not least I don't at least I
don't so anyways I apologize for the you
know I don't apologize oh I okay I will
I will I'll apologize for the podcast
being this late I was gonna do it on
Sunday when I was up in Foxwoods Joe
let's go to the [ __ ] casino out in
the middle of woods yo I was gonna
record on Sunday but uh virzi got some
tickets to see the Yukon Houston Cougars
game up uh you know big [ __ ] program
by the way man how about the fight you
know very quietly I probably shouldn't
say very quietly I just don't pay
attention to the sports ladies hopes you
know I knew that [ __ ] Tennessee with
Pat Summitt right was [ __ ] crushing
and I know UConn was I thought they were
doing all right but I thought it was
mainly [ __ ] Pat Summitt and then I
went to the goddamn UConn game I got a
picture of it here on my phone you know
somebody sent me a picture of a fretless
pitbull that had freckles it's the most
adorable thing you ever seen in your
life but the person said it looked like
making I like a good tweet you know I
don't give a [ __ ] if you break my balls
if it makes me laugh all right so the
[ __ ] leg the Lady Huskies well let's
do it in order here let's do the guys
first consider and they have way less
you know you always want to build
towards your closing bit alright the
guys the fellas have won four national
championships since 1999 all right the
UConn men's Huskies have won 1999
2004 2011 2014 that's very [ __ ]
respectable is anybody want more than
that
I don't know I'm not gonna look it up
Kentucky or Duke I would guess maybe not
Duke right do do oh alright um but the
ladies they won at 95 they won it in
2000 2002 2003 2004 2009 and then the
[ __ ] goddamn poor excuse for speakers
hanging from that [ __ ] building that
they have with the ceilings peeling is
in the way the next two banners they
want a 2014-2015 ow I got a [ __ ] look
it up well as far as what I can see here
on the phone that's one two three four
five six seven eight and there's two
other banners behind it that's got to be
a championship one yeah national
champions what an [ __ ] why the [ __ ]
didn't I walk down and take it correctly
oh maybe look it up before I did this
all right hang on a second hang on hang
on hang on
Jesus now I'm typing on my phone this is
gonna take for [ __ ] ever I looked
about the most random woman's Huskies
why would I write that that's not going
to get me there UConn Huskies
championships
all right give me the ladies give it the
ladies better come up first other men's
do you sexist [ __ ] national
championships you [ __ ] good
hang on ladies ladies they have a go
Connecticut women's basketball I
apologize I even know if I had if had
any [ __ ] decency I would edit most of
this out but I'm not gonna alright
national tournament championship a
conference championship jesus [ __ ]
christ nobody cares about any of this
Elite Eight Final Four tournament
champions 95 2000 2002 2003 2004 2009
2010 2013 2014 2015
one two three four five they wanted five
out of the last six [ __ ] years and
since the year member that cone a bit
they've wanted one two three four five
six seven eight nine [ __ ] times total
domination [ __ ] dogs snowing you know
my dog's getting fat I don't know what's
going on with him he's changed this food
we started getting her an extra can
because she's always [ __ ] coming over
licking the bowl there you know he felt
bad for and I should see if she looks
like a [ __ ] state worker right
Tennessee Lady Vols all right here we go
come on Wikipedia with a [ __ ] are you
Lady Vol what do you say what do you
think is we think has more huh I gotta
go with Connecticut at that point of
though this might be the most boring
podcast ever well what do you you know
you get what you pay for
alright [ __ ] it I'm not looking it up
any moment
Isaac see and see it double here very
impressed but both of them and their
quietly crushing it's a nice small
campus they play in this little ass
building with with [ __ ] peeling from the
ceiling the student section was
hilarious no when they introduced the
other team they'd sit there reading the
newspaper I thought that was funny now
I'm sure somebody's gonna say well LK
Alcorn [ __ ] University used to do
that I don't give a [ __ ] it's the first
time I saw it it was funny to me dude
there was a guy sitting behind us like
classic New England sports fan I never
heard a guy like anytime the ball didn't
go in for the Huskies he thought he had
a reason every [ __ ] time down the
court and this is what killed me so I'm
like alright this guy's a total hoop
head right and they turn around he has
on a Red Sox hat and t-shirt until he's
basically a sports maniac right the guys
missed a shot he'd be like hey I didn't
follow throw next time they come down
the court yeah that guy he should have
been rotating around least a second to
add the double team he should have been
rotating around next time down the court
somebody slips it was it what is a sub
wrong with the floor and I just kept
nudging Varzi he would he would go on
like like like the [ __ ] lady husky
he would go in like four five four five
hour runs there except instead of
winning championships he'd be like [ __ ]
moaning and complaining and at one point
he made a point you know they threw it
to their big goof there and that guy
[ __ ] missed the ball and the guy goes
you know if he had a pair of hands he
would've had two there and Frizzi
turnaround goes you know what you're
right and the guy just looked at him
with like an angry look like he was he
was so pissed that UConn was losing and
we actually you know I know they're only
having a mediocre year this year I mean
you can't [ __ ] win it every year but
you could sense when you were in there
the level how seriously everybody was
taken because Birds II kept saying like
wow these people take this [ __ ] really
seriously here and I just kept pointing
up to all the banners I'm like I would
say at this point that kind of used to
winning so I guess they're having a
disappointing year I guess I have no
idea I didn't look it up I just started
talking about it it's what I did but
that's why the podcast was not ready I
had a great time up at Foxwoods Resort
Casino 'he's by the way I want to thank
them for having me was their 24th
anniversary right so they say to me
before I get there they said is any way
before your first show if you could come
down there's a big dinner or something
we'd love if you could meet the the
tribal council and just stop by and say
hello right these are my employers for
the weekend what am I going to say no so
I'm like absolutely I want to meet these
Native Americans that [ __ ] beat the
white man you know and got their own
[ __ ] casino right so I go down there
and I just thought of something swimming
by a table and say hello to somebody
thank them for the gig and next thing
you know they got this whole business
like [ __ ] Eyes Wide Shut [ __ ]
dinner going on you know The Shining
kind of [ __ ] and the bowels of the
casino there's some band there's a stage
and there's like this guy smiley looking
[ __ ] political guy onstage and next
thing you know he's he's given me an
intro I had no [ __ ] idea I was going
on I have no idea what these people are
and furthermore these people had no idea
who I was and I just walked out I got we
got a local funny man yeah this weekend
please welcome comedian Bill
and I was standing see bringing me up
see if we get me up and I just [ __ ]
walk on stage I take the mic and I was
like I'm looking out at all these old
people and [ __ ] and they just stared at
me I was like I kind of had no idea I
was uh I was gonna be brought up here
but um you know congratulations on 24
years I'm sure most of you people here
know who the next four presidents are
gonna be on behalf of regular people if
you could do something about the
population problem I'd really appreciate
it and all of this [ __ ] is getting
nothing right I just started talking to
them like they were running the world
and just looking at me like I got
[ __ ] ten heads and I just said I just
sort of petered out and I went and
onward and upward I just handed it back
the guy smiley and there was just like a
little smattering of applause and I just
walked back into the hall with the
promoters we're walking I was like what
the what the [ __ ] was it I don't know
that's how we talk so I didn't know
wasn't route doctor awoke I was haunted
in a price reduction I'll just share how
large a table you know nobody knows
anything right they just [ __ ] wheel
you around
yeah then we just [ __ ] I think we got
on a golf cart at that point we know no
when we walked through the halls and
then they walked me by the crowd that
was going into my show so I look like a
complete jerk off I [ __ ] I love
seeing people after the show I [ __ ]
hate seeing people before the show I
don't know why I don't fits a
superstition it's just weird to me to be
for me to just be walking by like the
first time you see me I'm just walking
down the [ __ ] hall oh there's that
jerk off and then you just start looking
at why did I pay to see that look at him
but anyways we had a we had a great
[ __ ] time and a bunch of family and
friends coming out people hadn't seen in
years
do you don't my first best friend that I
ever had in life actually came up to the
gig and I hadn't seen him in 36 years
and I was actually thinking the last
time I saw him you know the reason why
my family moved away from the town
we had lived in and I just remember we
were both how [ __ ] old was I
I think we were like seven or eight and
you don't know how to say goodbye you
know I probably been friends with the
kids since I was like four so basically
half my life I was friends with this kid
so we loaded up the moving van the last
time like we would do in the u-haul
thing you know we'll do it ourselves and
we just made like 900 [ __ ] trips in
this thing and we were loading it up for
the last time and he lived across the
street from me so I walked down my
driveway and he was out there and he
knew this is he knows it I knew it was
it and we were just too young didn't
know yeah you know what to say it's
seven so some kid rode by and had just
written buying a bike and I remember he
just said something to me like oh yeah
that kid was trying to say that blah
blah blah blah I could remember anything
I was like oh yeah you know okay I was
like alright alright and he just started
to walk away and I walked away in the
other direction and we both looked over
our shoulder at the same time and then
that was it I got in the [ __ ] you
ball and that was it I think I came back
to the neighborhood like four years
later I saw him one other time so yeah
1980s I left in 76 saw him in 80 and
then I hadn't seen him since then so we
got caught up talking about the old
[ __ ] times man we didn't even get
into it either man Jesus Christ some of
the [ __ ] we used to do you know we used
to play with [ __ ] matches that's what
you used to do back then when there was
like like playing with matches was like
I don't know like having a Game Boy or
whatever these [ __ ] kids do nowadays
and his dad had these things we would
they will we call monkey matches it was
just a book of matches and for some
reason it just had a picture of a monkey
like wearing like a hat like like that
was like highbrow humor back then like
dressing monkeys up like human beings
you know and also having pictures of
dogs playing poker and [ __ ] passing
cards underneath the table with their
paws and [ __ ] you know so his dad for
whatever reason always had these match
books that have pictures of monkeys that
would like you know dress like dentists
you know like lab coats on and [ __ ] or
just some stupid [ __ ] hat you know
and so we would
this is what we do we would go over and
we would like basically underneath the
tree we would bunch up a bunch of pine
needles and you would just light it on
fire and just look at the fire and then
try and put it out and you know
sometimes you put it out sometimes you
didn't sometimes a neighbor would come
running over Christ let the [ __ ] cat
oh yeah Elliot don't I did that one time
I lit it and all of a sudden it just got
completely out of control and this guy
came running over the giant trashcan
they had filled up with water thank
[ __ ] christ
and and then somebody else in the
neighborhood I remember [ __ ] living
on fire let the whole [ __ ] woods on
fire and I know well I know it was too
because he rode down to the fire station
and and said that he didn't do it but he
knows that he knew that my friend did it
a [ __ ] ratted out my friend and I'm
sure the fire department was looking at
the kid looking and like listen you
little rat we know you [ __ ] did it
right so what I was cool to see him and
I think what the [ __ ] I'm talking about
it I hate doing this thing after I've
been on a [ __ ] plane you know oh you
know what I watched on the plane for the
second time I saw the movie a black mask
you know I know that that kind of got
mixed reviews that's one of those movies
you got to see it more than once see it
the second time the Johnny Depp is
[ __ ] unbelievable in that movie he's
un-fuckin'-believable
and there's a couple other actors there
I got to get their [ __ ] names they
were absolutely amazing but uh I liked
it the first time I loved it the second
time I saw it so you know I know I but
most people I heard from her from
Massachusetts is oh dude the [ __ ] XS
you just shut the [ __ ] up you know when
I went to Fargo they were bitching about
the [ __ ] accents in Fargo does that
mean Fargo is a bad movie well why don't
why don't we hire you who's not an actor
we'll have you [ __ ] do it we'll see
how that works out but um I just felt
you know the second time when I saw it
like the pacing of it I felt like it
they tied it in to like the absolute
sociopaths main character that they
would try you're so [ __ ] up as I'm
nervous about talking about that's the
level of power that those [ __ ] guys
it reminded me of the Shawshank
Redemption where a lot of people I know
the first time they saw that they didn't
like that movie because they felt it was
so long and was dragging on and on and
on and on but my mic theory on that
movie was they were giving you the sense
of what it was like to do time where it
becomes like this open-ended thing no
beginning no middle no end it actually
sounds like I'm [ __ ] on the movie
but it just the way it would fade down
and then just fade up and every time in
the crowd you'd like be anticipating
that there'd be this major turn and it
was just another day in prison a few
years later I kind of felt like they
were trying to do that with the Whitey
Bulger character where you know they
were saying like he was a sociopath like
they and how he slowly drew in the FBI
guys to the point that they were
entangled in his [ __ ]
and he insulated himself that way I
really I don't know maybe I was too dumb
to get all of that [ __ ] the first time
but the second time I watched it like I
said I went from liking that movie to
[ __ ] love in that movie so whatever
give it a shot if you haven't but um
speaking of which the [ __ ] Oscars
well last night huh white guys [ __ ]
crushing it oh we [ __ ] sweet cleaned
up last night just [ __ ] with you man
that was a I only got to see I got to
see Chris Rock's opening monologue which
I thought was great
I thought he handled the whole thing
[ __ ] perfectly and what else did I see
I didn't see a lot cuz right as it
started the show was starting I think we
had a nine o'clock show and started a
little bit after 8:00 but um I have no
idea who won what I know the Boston
movie about the [ __ ] pedophile priest
I heard that that thing one that was it
nobody fell down nothing else happened
right that it
oh very quietly the first Asian director
I believe ever [ __ ] once something is
that what I saw I don't know this is you
know just a reoccurring thing I'm not
gonna look anything up I'm just gonna
start talking about it and you know
that's gonna be it you know what I don't
understand like I don't understand the
weight that people put on the [ __ ]
Oscars oh I really got to tell you that
though you know what I mean I just don't
I don't [ __ ] get it
I was joking this weekend like just
sitting there watching a bunch of adults
running around wanting to win a trophy
it's like what are you in [ __ ] Little
League trophies are for kids aren't they
you have ribbons and [ __ ] and it makes
them feel good you take him out for a
[ __ ] snow cone and then that's it you
know you put him to bed you get yourself
a whiskey and you sit there and you
stare at the wall and that's basically
your life I mean what do you how old are
you you need a [ __ ] trophy yeah I
don't I don't give a [ __ ] about like
that type of stuff but I definitely
think that there should be opportunity
for everybody you know I'd like to hear
everybody's stories so I had no problem
with any of that [ __ ] but I do just
think it's funny that people [ __ ]
flip out and start crying about winning
a goddamn trophy and this trophy means
more than that trophy this wants more
prestigious
all right let's I gotta do a couple
Reed's here for this week
how the [ __ ] am i lookin on there all
right
Jesus crate trunk club everybody no
matter what time of year it is you have
got to make every second count
no you don't you can chill out you know
you can sit down on a deck or maybe in
your neighbor's deck if he's not home
and just I can put your feet up and
enjoy yourself no matter what time of
year it is you've got to make every
second count it sounds like a workout
video and that means looking your best
no more ratty jeans are oversized
hoodies recent college graduates it's
time to upgrade your wardrobe and let
trunk Club handle all the work for you
trunk club takes the hassle man out of
shopping by finding the best clothes for
you and your style you'll look and feel
amazing
and we'll always have the perfect
clothes for your season oh my god Todd I
can't believe how good you look sorry
a truck club.com slash burp you answer
simple questions about your style
preferences thighs and our assigned and
experts stylist
what do you mean actually they're
working for trunk club if they were an
expert when they have a own [ __ ] line
of clothing your stylist will hand pick
clothes from the best premium brands
just approve of what you like and send
back what you don't like and just like
that a trunk full of [ __ ] clothes
alive arrives right on your doorstep
filled with hand-picked clothes that are
perfect for you try them on keep what
you like yeah try them on don't just
stare them out you know oh just look at
them stupid
keep what you like and easy to return
what you don't in their prepaid trunk
trunk Club is not a subscription service
you only pay for the clothes you keep
from your trunk no hidden charges just
great clothes get started today at trunk
club and trunk club sorry will style you
for free plus free shipping both ways
you only pay for the clothes that you
keep take to take advantage go to trunk
club calm / / that's trunk Club calm / /
hey trunk Club calm / / all right dolly
shade club everybody mmm you guys
evidently according to this copy I've
figured it out evidently I've discovered
the key to an amazing shave isn't that
so weird that they would write that like
the like I like I would actually say
that hey guys I've figured it out and
you'd be like one I'm not to work and
make more money no better than that
I've start I discovered the key to an
amazing shave sorry alright you know but
why would you have that big of a [ __ ]
intro for something as stupid as just
shaving your face okay the reality here
is you have you get you get a good shave
for a little amount of money that that's
all that's going on here okay we're not
curing cancer let's get back to the copy
it's simple that's exactly what
dollarshaveclub.com does and why you
could be a proud member like millions of
others dollarshaveclub.com delivers a
Razors right to your door for a third of
the price of what those greedy razer
corporation [ __ ] charge both your
wallet in your face finally get some
relief Jonny dollarshaveclub.com means
you can afford to shave with a fresh
blade anytime you want which feels
fantastic and for the smoothest shave
ever use their fresh use your fresh
Dollar Shave Club blade with their
doctor CAV easy it's not your average
shave cream it's high-quality
ingredients that make your skin feel
soft smooth and moisturize your blade
will glide gently across your skin if
you want the most amazing shape possible
take it from me use a fresh Dollar Shave
Club blade and dr. cabbies easy shave
butter two reasons to join
dollarshaveclub.com slash bar today
that's dollarshaveclub.com slash / and
lastly but certainly not least Lee our
old friends stamps.com hey everyone your
to-do-list can seem out of control so
much to do but so little time but
there's one thing you could check off
your to-do list that's going to the
goddamn [ __ ] cocksuckin post
office thanks to stamps calm with stamps
calm you can buy and print official US
postage right from your own computer or
printer stamps calm we'll send you a
digital scale alright you can weigh your
drugs on it and mail something to your
grandmother automatically it calculates
the exact postage you need for any
letter a package any class of mail print
the postage you need put it on your
letter a package and then just hand it
to your mail carrier and you're done
alright I use stamps com anytime I'm
selling [ __ ] after my show and I'm a
[ __ ] if I can figure it out oh god damn
it so can you and if not you can find
someone that can help you out right now
use my last name bur for this special
offer four week trial plus at under $10
bonus offer which includes the digital
scale and up to fifty five dollars free
postage for Christ's sake don't wait go
to stamps calm before you do anything
else click on the microphone at the top
of the homepage and type in Barbie URR
that's stamps calm enter BRR alright and
with that it's mercifully over
it's MRSA flea OVA all right I don't
know if you guys know this but I guess
they're working on cars that are gonna
drive themselves in the future I don't
know why I mean how [ __ ] lazy are
people gonna get I mean it's gonna be
great for drinking and driving
it'd just be drinking and writing you
know you all of a sudden you'll always
have that [ __ ] thing right but I
don't I don't like this man I don't like
how everything's becoming [ __ ]
automated you know I feel like rich
people are gradually phasing us out you
know because you know goddamn well the
only reason why they allow us to exist
is cuz they need us to farm right they
need us to deliver [ __ ] they need us to
do a bunch of [ __ ] i guy could add
another example I don't know dance
around like a monkey at a [ __ ] casino
come downstairs and say a couple of
words at your little [ __ ] Illuminati
party in the basement they need us to do
that but once everything is automated
and it just handles it it's [ __ ] self
do you think you could be a part of that
group what if you were part of a group
that was just gonna slowly [ __ ] just
phase everybody else out you know and
somehow it would happen in your lifetime
all right like who would you keep these
are very Hitler s type questions but
this is the type of [ __ ] madness that
I think everybody's capable of you know
especially I don't know if you travel on
the road some of the dopes you [ __ ]
meet out there watching people getting
stirred up you know in all honesty I
can't stand like the choices that we
have for president right now you know is
it starts to go towards as a [ __ ]
torpedo that [ __ ] Saint Bernard
looking guy Bernie Sanders right in his
jowls as a torpedo his [ __ ] campaign
and all Democrats are walking around he
can't wear it he Garrett went I love
that I love it yeah because you're too
much of a [ __ ] to [ __ ] vote for him
that's why right so you're gonna vote
for this [ __ ] this clammy [ __ ]
crook or this guy who isn't saying
anything but like I really believe that
you know you could talk people into
[ __ ] wiping out everybody on the
planet
he's very easily just listening to
Donald Trump his speeches where he just
says absolutely nothing
you know he said today he was talking to
college graduates and he's literally
going like I'm going to bring jobs back
to the United States you wait there's
gonna be more jobs here by the time I'm
done it's gonna make your head spin now
I'm gonna have I'm gonna have Apple
bring manufacturing jobs back from China
to here okay and people clapped he never
has to say how he's gonna do all I'm
gonna plug up the hole in the ozone
layer waters gonna be clear I'm gonna
get rid of all terrorism and that's
gonna be the first week I like this guy
this guy makes sense he's making it
great again you know and then he got
Hillary out she just talks to her
[ __ ] teeth it's like she you know she
looks like she should be doing like a
ventriloquist act but the puppet isn't
there I don't know I don't know I don't
know I don't [ __ ] know no idea and I
don't even know who the other guys are I
just heard a couple of them talking
trying to trash Donald Trump and they
just they sounded pathetic just not good
speakers this is just this is a bad one
this is a bad one you know I got bet
people watching you know you know if you
got a great college program and a bunch
of seniors [ __ ] graduate graduate you
just you know you just go through a bad
4-year period I think that's what we're
coming through we're coming out oh right
now you know like this one guy he was
saying who's gonna get rid of Obamacare
if he was elected and people like
applauding like I don't [ __ ] get it I
don't get why I don't even I don't have
Obamacare I guess my tax dollars pay for
it but I don't have any problem with
somebody like I don't want my fellow
countrymen walking around with a [ __ ]
toothache
they just spleen removed [ __ ] you figure
it out for yourself why don't we help
each other out a little more you know
what can we do that and if elected
anybody needs this spleen out Donald
Trump I bet I could run I could run for
president if that's all you got to do is
just say you're gonna do all this
awesome [ __ ] you never [ __ ] do it
everyone will have health care and it
will be free
all right um oh this weekend by the way
no the self-driving cars let's get back
to that [ __ ] thing so evidently some
self-driving car hit a bus which is
[ __ ] tremendous for anybody who loves
driving that is such a tremendous [ __ ]
thing that happened today or yesterday
or maybe last year all I know is I just
found the [ __ ] story I'm so [ __ ]
psyched
it's the self-driving car hit the
[ __ ] hit the [ __ ] bus I mean it
even though I was only going like 2
miles an hour it's just so [ __ ] great
because it hit a bus so all you gotta
say is just you know just be like well
what if what if there was a bunch of
kids on that bus right and then that'll
delay in a good 20 [ __ ] years let me
see if I can find this story
self-driving google says it bears some
responsibility after self-driving car
hits bus can you [ __ ] believe that
well was this was there a person driving
the bus I would say that you you you
have all the [ __ ] responsibility
unless this guy literally drove into the
[ __ ] thing alphabet incorporate
incorporated Google said on Monday it
bears some responsibility after one of
its self-driving cars struck a municipal
bus in a minor crash earlier this month
the crash may be the first case of one
of its autumn autonomous cars hitting
another vehicle and the fault of the
self-driving car dude this is gonna be a
[ __ ] show this is just one and it
already hit a [ __ ] bus you know what
I mean that's [ __ ] that's lunacy it's
[ __ ] lunacy men I will tell you it I
mean I think it'll it will it will cause
people to drink like they've never drank
before I mean half most nights I don't
drink out here because I you know I
Drive myself places you know I don't
[ __ ] over well that'll put Eber out
of business right I guess if you don't
have a [ __ ] car I don't know don't
you guys like driving I hope you have
like the option my thing is how is the
insurance gonna work
you know goddamn well there's no way the
insurance company is gonna take that
[ __ ] liability on and then they're
claiming they're gonna get rid of
there'll be no more deaths from car
accidents there's gonna be no more
accidents it's just gonna be it's gonna
be like just accident free and this is
amazing to me that this that it's gotten
this [ __ ] far considering you know
that like the amount of times they tried
to kill the electric car right you know
big oil companies that type of thing I
mean you're [ __ ] with their their blue
blood money you went out having that
let's go electrocute an elephant to show
how [ __ ] dangerous these cars are
right so like there's the only thing I
can think what will these insurance
companies they're making enough money to
go down there and whack somebody at ABC
incorporated right you know they [ __ ]
do [ __ ] like that you go to a diner and
all of a sudden you stagger out go and
they poison me and you do a faceplant
then your invention disappears this is
why I think they're letting this one go
through because they're eventually gonna
get rid of all of us and when they do
that they're gonna have no more limo
drivers so they're like well what are we
gonna do in the future if we want a rug
somewhere I mean I'm not going to drive
my car and soil my wealthy hands in oh
my and then somebody's like what what if
we just had it will just make the cars
drive themselves okay then okay kill
them all then yes thank you
poison them remove them from the planet
I don't if they got rid of everybody how
long it would take for this [ __ ] you
know to go back to normal you have to
take all the nuclear waste right just
send it out you know up in the [ __ ]
space right send it towards Mars just
make sure you don't hit the moon and all
you do is just [ __ ] chill out nearly
your little house I went how long it
would take to undo all Apple all this
[ __ ] that people leave behind you know
[ __ ] you're gonna do with all of that
that's all gonna go into the soil I take
a liliane toi what happened in your
lifetime
Jesus Christ I am all over the place man
what the [ __ ] am I talking about here
murdering people and self-driving cars
you should see this [ __ ] car by the
way
this [ __ ] self-driving car makes the
Volkswagen Beetle look like a goddamn
Lamborghini people on the simpsons drive
a better looking car than that [ __ ]
thing well you know they're all gonna be
the exact same [ __ ] one right you'll
have your options of like three
different colors like white black or
beige oh man this is not uplifting I'll
tell you what's uplifting March 5th this
weekend UFC 196 conor mcgregor UFC 196
what are they calling this one did they
stop naming them that by the way - have
they come up with a hundred 96
adjectives that describe a [ __ ]
tremendous that sports that sport is you
know there was a UFC 12 the redemption
the revenge whatever they always had
like these cool [ __ ] names up to once
you get up to like 196 they got to be
running out right let me see what they
got here UFC 196 Conor McGregor vs. some
guy Diaz I wish I knew these guys name
better I'm I'm you know there's only so
much [ __ ] I could pay attention to he's
taking on late replacement Nate Diaz
that Jesus what happened he was supposed
to fight somebody else
Raffi oh I'm not gonna [ __ ] insulted
latinas by trying to pronounce it
although I could give you a good laugh
here rafael dos anos rafael dos anos was
bounced from his showdown against Conor
with a broken foot have it the [ __ ] do
you know I was reading something on
McGregor today do you know I don't know
somebody in the fight game please
explain this to me that guy walks around
at 170 and he's shredded and then before
his fight for whatever [ __ ] reason
he's got to go down to 145 now I can
understand if the other guy just walks
around at one
45 or maybe 155 in Connor for whatever
reason just wants to beat the [ __ ] out
of the guy so he's willing to starve
himself down to 145 for the love of God
can anybody in the fight game that let
that does this
why can't you know if Connor walks
around at 170 and the other guys walking
around at 165 why don't they just fight
it like 160 why do they gotta bring
everybody all the way the [ __ ] down
there I I just don't understand why they
got to do that [ __ ]
check out the Sports Illustrated article
on on Conor McGregor they got like this
whole thing where they only briefly
talked about it
but they're talking about cutting weight
and it actually sounds in a lot of ways
worse than the fight like talking about
the pain and the agony of it and it's I
can't even I'm not gonna be able to do
it justice because I just read it I have
a very poor memory and I've never gone
through it but uh Holly Holmes also
fighting against me Miesha Tate and I'm
taking a night off from stand up and I'm
gonna [ __ ] hang you know what's great
this is the one sport that I can really
watch my wife like she likes going to
live hoop too but she loves the [ __ ]
UFC she gets into it like at a crazy
level like that time when he that guy
kicked kicked the other dude and he had
the compound fracture you know and his
[ __ ] leg bent all the way back I was
just like I walked outta my guy done
done I can't watch that she was
rewinding it wanted to watch it again
and was like like literally interested
in it which means she either should have
been a serial killer or gotten into the
medical field because if you can [ __ ]
stomach that either way I can I'm really
excited to see this [ __ ] this weekend I
like it even if it that quick fights you
know if it's a bad thing doesn't it make
you at least want to work out you see
those guys and [ __ ] women getting in
and they're all [ __ ] jacked you look
it down at yourself
usually finishing off a pizza like what
the [ __ ] am i doing going down to Home
Depot tomorrow I'll get a sledge hammer
and a big [ __ ] tire you know and you
know what you do it for a couple days
and then you quit that's why
like what you're gonna see on [ __ ]
Saturday there you go there's my promo
for the UFC all right let's uh let's
let's read some [ __ ] letters for this
week shall we everybody chances are
because we Cleo you're losing your
figure sweetheart glad you didn't walk
the red carpet at the at the [ __ ]
Oscars they would have been all over you
all right leaving the country of Trump
wins dear Billy elect what should take
on people who say they're going to leave
the country if Trump wins
besides the potential for lanes to open
up on the highway I just hope the people
that say they're going to leave leave so
I don't have to point out who's a lying
sack of [ __ ]
they're obviously joking no one's gonna
leave this country but uh it's just you
know he's a very extreme guy you know I
think people said that when Obama they
definitely said it during George Bush
was some famous star said it I remember
I thought it was like funny then of
course Fox News is all our Julie why
don't you get the [ __ ] out of here you
like [ __ ] lunacy what do I think
about people say that I think it's kind
of hacky at this point I think that's
what everybody says when there's
somebody that's on the fringe on one
side of the other somebody always ends
up going dude [ __ ] winter want to
leave where you gonna go this is what
people forget when you when you leave
this country you you immediately become
an immigrant who's taking somebody
else's job in the country that you're
going to and you get treated as such you
know even if you white they don't want
but they don't Americans moving up to
Canada [ __ ] with that population
taking their jobs you know all of a
sudden you're standing this driving a
spike into a tree to take out some maple
syrup instead of the other guy they
don't want that all right yeah I just
think they're just the same I mean it's
it's [ __ ] scary I mean it's both
scary I think Hillary's a [ __ ] lying
sack of [ __ ] a totally dishonest and I
think Donald Trump is a reality show
star
that's the best we can [ __ ] do just
don't [ __ ] get it it keeps getting
worse
jesus [ __ ] the last guy the last guy
that I thought was decent was the first
George Bush you know I'm like when he
went into Kuwait and then like he eats
it alright that's enough that's enough
he didn't go all [ __ ] nuts and we got
the [ __ ] out of there you know and then
[ __ ] Clinton came and I what the [ __ ]
that was a big frat party he's getting
his dick sucked he's lying about [ __ ]
people got stuff on him mysteriously
died I mean it was [ __ ] nuts then he
bombed some people to get out of a
[ __ ] [ __ ] accusation the whole
[ __ ] thing was I don't know it's been
crazy ever since um I don't know [ __ ]
about politics don't listen to me
alright
boyfriend's smoking habit hey mr. burr
loved the podcast and the stand-up come
to Rochester New York soon I would love
oh you know what you know what there's a
buffalo date and a Syracuse date in the
works yes ma'am yes sir whatever whoever
this is writing the [ __ ] with a fire
just scroll down sorry loved the podcast
understand I've come to Rochester New
York I would appreciate some advice from
yourself and the lovely Nia if she's
available she ain't here today man all
right I've been with my boyfriend for
almost two years and since day one I
knew of his daily weed smoking habit he
doesn't let her let it hinder his life
still very social faithful going to
going to work every day he's scheduled
he eats healthy and he goes to the gym
four to five days a week I've tried
getting used to it since it's something
that he does and it isn't a problem in
his life but I've never wanted to try
drugs or alcohol so I don't know what
the feeling of being under the influence
of something is like now because not
because of that my problem is unless I
see him during the day
and even then it'll take a hit he's not
sober
is it wrong of me to be concerned
whenever he sees me he's under the
influence of something whenever we go to
the movies or a comedy show he'll bring
half a cookie so he can quote enjoy the
show more and why don't I want him to
relax after work by vaping a bag and
hanging out with me
considering this habit hasn't hindered
his life in any way do I have a reason
to be uneasy about this I understand why
he does it and he tells me it doesn't
affect his feeling about feelings about
me and about us being together but it
still makes me uneasy whenever I know
he's high yeah well I mean if you don't
like it you don't like it and if he
enjoys it he enjoys it so you both know
where you stand I got to be honest I
mean if someone was drinking every day
that would be probably an issue with
that although there's no medicinal
purposes for alcohol is there unless
they've taken an arrow out of your back
don't think like rub some on your gums
or some [ __ ] I can't remember how it
goes you take a shot is that what it is
you bite down on a [ __ ] garden hose I
don't remember yeah I mean if he's
getting [ __ ] baked all the time and
he always you know so we'll enjoy it
more yeah that's a little bit of a red
flag I you know honestly if you're
[ __ ] doing it every day and you're
never really sober he just sort of
constantly just sort of hi that's
probably not a good way to go through
life but it is his choice I would just
tell him just be like look I'm not
saying you can't smoke but like you give
you're high all the time and I'm sober
so I'm constantly talking to a buzzed
you and it bothers me I would just tell
him that and I I think that it's gonna
bother him because when you [ __ ]
smoke weed like that it's a religion you
know what I mean it's not like you know
every day he comes home and he does this
one little thing puts his shoes in the
wrong spot or some [ __ ] this is like
you're talking about his state of
consciousness when he's around you at
all [ __ ] times basically you want him
to alter that so that's some kind of a
major change he didn't tell me how old
he was
but I don't know I don't know much about
wheat I know some people say they get
productive when when they're when
they're using it and that type of stuff
but uh I don't know I I really feel that
you know and this is somebody who's like
realized that his drinking is out of
control again so I just sort of stopped
for the last [ __ ] three days I mean I
really have to watch it with myself okay
because I have the kind of job where you
know I can get [ __ ] up every night
basically and then sleep in the next day
now granted my career would suffer and I
wouldn't get anywhere and eventually you
know but I mean I could do some before
like my career totally did a [ __ ]
nosedive provided I didn't like you know
do something stupid like [ __ ] you
know get behind the wheel of a car
[ __ ] assault somebody if I was just
getting drunk every day
yeah that would affect where I was in
the business but it'd be like a long 7
year like tapering off you know back to
doing the comedy vault at Remington's in
Boston which doesn't exist anymore but
you know I I don't know I I just
personally I know I really got to watch
it in my my thing about people who smoke
weed is the fact that they can be on it
and nobody really knows like you know
and once they're high all the time
they're experienced being high and they
can just go to work being high and you
can't do that drunk you can't go to work
like you know shotgun a beer and walk in
people just know it just doesn't work
[Music]
but I'm not exactly the 100% exact
against it the way I used to in the
early days of this podcast when I didn't
know a lot about it now I'm
understanding that there's certain
people you know if they have really
active minds they need to [ __ ] chill
out it's actually a great thing for them
but I really think if you're doing it
all the [ __ ] time like that yeah like
this it's probably cause for an issue
there you know to bring it up like hey
you kind of [ __ ] basically wasted
every time I talk to you and then also
you know that whole thing you know he
brings half a cookie so he can enjoy the
show it's like you can't enjoy it sober
like those are kind of
some red flags I don't know and I also
think that you can get addicted to that
[ __ ] you know I think you're I think a
guy is to be honest with you people
always saying now you're not really
addicted to it oh yeah you just do it
every waking moment
you can't [ __ ] enjoy something unless
you're under the influence of it there's
something there it's just because it's
such a mellow thing and it's not like
you know I got I got a bunny mine from
back in the day - he's completely
[ __ ] addicted to that [ __ ] he says I
love weak because it turns my life into
a movie and you know he's basically been
high since we were sophomores in high
school and without a doubt it's [ __ ]
with his memory without a doubt it's
it's [ __ ] with his Drive you know I
don't know but I understand wanting to
get [ __ ] up every day personally it's
fun everything with weed it's so easy a
couple of puffs and then boom you're
there you know drink it takes a lot yeah
I got to stop talking about this um I
have a drink I'd said I'd take a week
off here so all right well good luck
with that I would just I would just say
how you feeling and if he gives you know
gives you [ __ ] back I just feel like
look you mean I'm not being an [ __ ]
here you just like you're high every day
can you just like not be high a couple
days a week but like how do you do that
not feel like you're infringing on this
guy's [ __ ] lifestyle yeah that's
I don't know I would bring it up to him
as I said 20 minutes ago before I
meandered my way through that sorry
about that
all right I [ __ ] up please advise dear
Billy ginger cakes I am a 26 year old
[ __ ] leg
[Music]
who's a tremendous fan of your work in
all its glorious forms well thank you
very much that's seen enough is for
family with the dad balls when bill is
stuck under the bed is the funniest
[ __ ] thing I've ever seen brilliant
well thank you I appreciate that
I did I did something really then all
capitals really dumb and I would greatly
appreciate your insight because I know
you will tell me the ever-elusive truth
I want to tell you why well I'll tell
you what I think is the truth whether
it's the right answer you got it you got
to decide that for yourself I have been
friends with this guy for about two
years and now you [ __ ] them and you
ruin the friendship that's what I'm so
that's what I'm guessing here we met
through a larger group of friends there
was chemistry between us immediately
this guy is Sophie's married trying to
see where how how how this can go off
the rails this are this this is reading
in the beginning like one of those
dating sites you know they play that
stupid piano Lou do but do do that's
stupid dumb [ __ ] a serial killer this
could be a sex offender I don't know we
met through a larger group of friends
there was chemistry between us
immediately this guy is so funny and so
smart and fun to be around the problem
is he has two penises I'm kidding she
didn't write that but he's also a
complete and total [ __ ] oh Jesus
crushing it and good for him but exactly
the wrong guy to get hung up on I knew I
liked him too much I couldn't help it
but I thought I could handle being
friends and friends with him and
eventually eventually the feelings would
pass nah now you can't be around guys
like that
this guy's a [ __ ] getting
son-of-a-bitch right Dracula would be
like god damnit that guy's got game
right now all the ladies love Dracula
he'd come up start gnawing on their
[ __ ] necks and that was it turn him
into Lady bats right then he'd kick him
to the curb get himself another chick
the next day we started hanging out a
lot at least two or three nights a week
sometimes he said things that made me
maybe he liked me too then on my
birthday we got drunk and had sex called
it oh Jesus
she says let me be clear he started it
I just didn't stop it even though I knew
it was a bad idea he's like a little kid
he started it
the worst part is when I woke up the
next morning in his bed in his bed he
was gone oh man he fled the [ __ ]
scene bill the dude shaped hole in the
door what told me that he was freaked
out
the dude shaped hole in the door you
mean he was like Lily ran through the
door I think you left some words out or
I'm too [ __ ] old to understand is
that some new slang told me he was too
freaked out and decided and I decided to
give him some space he called me four
days later I don't remember the
conversation well were you drunk but he
said he'd called me back that was four
months ago clearly he doesn't give a
[ __ ] I get that but I cannot understand
how he could be so much in my life and
then just never [ __ ] talk to me again
the [ __ ] dude the [ __ ] you sound cool as
hell by the way the more immediate
problem is that in a few weeks a mutual
friend is having a birthday party and
dude is gonna because gonna be there
what the [ __ ] do I do bill how do I face
him do I confront him do I ignore him
I'm buggin out please help me thank you
and any advice from me has got a gun I
wish she was here this week all right
here's the deal all right this isn't
about him this is about you all right
be honest with yourself you kind of said
you knew what this guy was you knew who
he was
all right but he just had that [ __ ]
thing all right he just had that [ __ ]
charisma or whatever and two years two
years into it you drunk he started it
and you went through it there whatever
you know he got freaked out and
confirmed what you knew all the time and
he [ __ ] left
all right now be honest with me do you
want to fight that fight before you met
this guy and you fantasized about the
man you were gonna marry was this how it
was gonna play out what's this this is
something that you want to [ __ ] deal
with you realize you're gonna have to
like trying to bring this [ __ ] fish
in the amount of heartache the amount of
extracurricular activities and all that
[ __ ] [ __ ] that comes along with a guy
like this well why would you do that why
would you do that to yourself you don't
need this [ __ ]
alright the problem is is you're trying
to like you're trying to like figure out
the sanity in somebody's insane behavior
okay you knew what he was and then he
confirmed it and now you're like what
does he mean this he's in today how
could he just do that cuz he's a [ __ ]
lunatic he's a lunatic who knows because
his dad ran around on his mom because
his mom took off on his dad who the [ __ ]
knows because he his [ __ ]
his giant truckload of [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay that he has still not even begun to
deal with which is why he's behaving
like that around you you don't [ __ ]
need that Jesus Christ all the guys in
the [ __ ] world
go to the party and have a good time
just tell him just you know if you see
him just say what's up no need to be
weird okay it's over whatever where we
had a good time it's [ __ ] over I knew
you were nuts and now you confirmed it
alright stop [ __ ] looking at me like
you seen it go like I just I would just
go there and have a good time I wouldn't
ignore him
I wouldn't confront him I would just say
hello and then I would go on what to
happen if he wants to talk talk to him
if he doesn't just go on with having a
good time if you bump into him again say
hello again but don't let that [ __ ]
guy ruin your good time alright and quit
[ __ ] wasting mental time trying to
figure out his [ __ ] he's not worth
it [ __ ] them
all right there you go [ __ ] them hey
Kuno she might meet mr. right at that
place hmm this could be the everlasting
look documentary suggestion dear Billy
boo if you haven't seen the documentary
on Netflix about the Ukraine revolution
you should definitely check it out I
would love to see that
it's called winter on fire that sounds
like a really bad eighty song wait
you're on fire what was that saying
almost fire I could fight some [ __ ]
Russians I don't like bad amia Boonton
I'm sorry in the immortal words of Ron
Burgundy
while that escalated quickly my singing
or the the documentary it starts with
some activists deciding to congregate in
one place which started as an event sent
out on Facebook and ended up replacing
their president yeah every time I
reached you like this like I am amazed
at the human spirit and also feels so
[ __ ] lucky that I haven't had to
experience that in a country you know
and in the country I live in we haven't
gone through some [ __ ] like that
hopefully it'll never [ __ ] happen
because I don't think I could stomach it
you know hearing people running up and
down the street and you just sitting
there in the house the idea is so
foreign to us I think most people don't
understand just how crazy it is yeah I
mean I don't I'm trying to wrap my head
around it but you are really good at
seeing crazy [ __ ] no one notices that is
right under our noses so I think you'll
be floored by this thanks and go [ __ ]
yourself well thank you for the the
recommendation I will definitely try to
check that out as soon as I can is that
all the [ __ ] is that all the [ __ ]
what am i up to here 58 minutes and 56
seconds I think I can [ __ ] for
another minute and call this a goddamn
day was there something else that I had
to talk about here on the podcast oh
yeah I decided uh I ran into a buddy of
mine and he told me his New Year's New
Year's resolution was he wasn't going to
argue
his wife this year and he's made it all
the way to February I was like you know
what that's a really cool resolution and
I haven't made any this year so I'm not
giving up arguing with my wife for two
reasons one it would destroy my act and
two I'm a selfish son of a [ __ ] I just
I have no control of my [ __ ] emotions
I don't it's shameful but I don't
so I decided instead I'm gonna I'm
trying to get back into learning French
I feel like as I'm approaching you know
the mid-century mark here if I don't
[ __ ] do it now I'm gonna be [ __ ]
I'm never gonna learn how to do it so
I'm [ __ ] on back into it I'm on
duolingo I've done in three days in a
[ __ ] row and the only reason why I'm
announcing it to you guys is because if
you don't hear me talking about it
please break my balls and say that I
[ __ ] quit again I'm a loser and all
that type of [ __ ] all that wonderful
positive [ __ ] that you guys can say
anonymously on the internet oh by the
way you know you know it's funny in this
[ __ ] business like they never tell
the performer [ __ ] right so I'm on stage
this weekend I got an acid if there's
any doctors out there I'm [ __ ]
onstage and I'm doing my act I don't
even know what night it was I might've
been the first show last night and the
whole time I'm doing my act everything I
[ __ ] say some guy in the crowd he's
just like repeating it or commenting on
it you know I mean like not like
heckling it's more like like black
church like call-and-response I was like
yeah you know I was walking down the
street the other day and he says are ya
well I'm down straight you know doing
that [ __ ] the whole [ __ ] time but
he's not so loud that the rest of the
crowd can hear it so I'm hoping if I
just ignore him he's gonna stop and he
doesn't it finally act like a half an
hour's like dude will you shut the [ __ ]
up you don't have to [ __ ] comment on
everything he said all right all right
all right he's just doing that [ __ ] but
I love you take st. [ __ ] like that and
you know I was trashing him and all that
[ __ ] so afterwards I ended up meeting
him after the show and he ended up
telling me that he had Tourette's and
then somebody on the show goes yeah yeah
yeah
we don't know if you should throw him on
it's like why don't you [ __ ] tell me
that before I make a [ __ ] ass out of
myself I felt terrible but it is my
question is that a form of Tourette's I
thought Tourette's is either your curse
in your brains out or you make weird
noises or you do some sort of physical
tic I didn't know that you [ __ ] all
of a sudden we're doing that you know
I'm in a Baptist Church you know except
doing it in a way that eggs on the
[ __ ] speaker it actually annoys the
[ __ ] out of it well maybe that's my
temperament I have no idea that's my
question for somebody out there in the
medical field is that a form of
Tourette's what was he just trying to
make me feel bad I'm literally yawning
here like a [ __ ] idiot all right
that's the podcast for this week
Oh biz Billy no booze bag he's back on
the [ __ ] wagon again I got to tell
you as much as I [ __ ] go up and down
with that [ __ ] at least I do nip it in
the bud you know I I just drank too much
was it Friday night woke up [ __ ]
hungover tired as [ __ ] I was just like
what the [ __ ] am i doing to myself this
is stupid and then I watched black mask
and I was watching them drinking
Budweiser's in 1970s pull-tab cans and I
was like god I missed that
I missed it already all right all right
that's a podcast for this week sorry it
was so late if you'd like to contribute
to this podcast as I tell you that it's
late anytime you go to Amazon just go
through the podcast page look at the
podcast page through my website click on
the March page you click on the amazon
link and i get credit for driving people
there and I give 10% of that [ __ ] to st.
Jude until you tell me that that one's a
scam too you know everyone that I give
to you guys eventually end up telling me
that but I think this is a good one all
right go [ __ ] yourself so talk to you on
Thursday